- {Voiceover] Phototropism in plants is a
response in which a plant shoot grows
toward a light source.
The results of five different experimental
treatments from classic investigations
of phototropism are shown above.
Part A: Give support for the claim that
the cells located in the
tip of the plant shoot
give support for the claim that the cells
located in the tip of the plant shoot
detect the light by comparing the results
from treatment group one with
the results from treatment group two
and treatment group three.
So we wanna compare these first
three treatment groups, and you see when
you have an unaltered tip that the whole
plant is going to bend in
the direction of the light,
when you remove the tip, it no longer
bends in the direction of the light,
or if you were to cover the tip with
some type of an opaque cap so the light
can't go through it, it's
still not going to bend.
So this is pretty good
evidence that there is
there is something about
the tip of the plant
that allows the phototropism to occur,
it allows the plant to
know which direction
the light is and then makes somehow causes
it to bend in that direction.
So I'll just write that down.
Give support for the claim,
so we can say that phototropism
phototropism
only occurred only occurred when
there is an
unaltered tip unaltered tip
that has access to the light
that has access to light.
No bending occurred no bending occurred
occurred when either the tip was removed
the tip was removed
that was that was treatment two
so treatment treatment two,
or the tip was tip had an opaque cover,
the tip had an opaque cover,
that was treatment treatment
treatment three.
So that's all there is
to it, it only occurred
when there was an unaltered tip, so that
was treatment one that
has access to light,
no bending occurred when
either the tip was removed
in this one, in treatment two,
or treatment three, so it's a pretty good
indication that you need that tip and it
needs to have access to light,
something about the
tip lets the plant know
what direction to start bending in.
All right, let's do part B now.
Part B.
In treatment groups four and five,
so that's these two treatment groups
right over here, the tips
of the plants are removed
and placed back onto the shoot on either
a permeable or impermeable barrier.
Using the results from treatment groups
four and five, describe two
additional characteristics
of the phototropism response.
Well, when the tip was placed on top of a
permeable barrier, the phototropism
still happens, the plant still bends.
So even though the tip is disconnected,
because this barrier is permeable,
the tip must be able
to sense the light and
release some type of substance or hormone
or chemical or something that's able to
go through this permeable barrier,
some type of substance that goes through
this permeable barrier, and somehow
signals to the rest of the plant to bend
in the right direction.
Because when you put
an impermeable barrier
right over here, the tip
might be trying to release
those same substances but they can't get
through and so the rest
of the plant doesn't
know to bend or in what direction to bend.
So we could say, we could say
tip, tip must release some type
of hormone hormone I say chemical
chemical that signals to
rest of plant to bend to bend
and in which direction which direction
we know this, we know this,
because
only the or only I
could say treatment four
only treatment four treatment four
permeable barrier, and I'll say
where the barrier's permeable to that
substance, where the barrier
is permeable to that substance
that substance we know this because
only treatment four where the barrier
is permeable to the substance
shows shows phototropism, phototropism.
Not treatment treatment five.
We know this, we could say, because
of the two, of four and
five, only treatment
four where the barrier's permeable
to that substance shows phototropism.
That's the only explanation here,
that it's not doing somehow doing it
through radio waves or
releasing substances
that somehow float in the air to the rest
of the plant, that somehow some type
of substance is going through through
directly from the tip to
the rest of the plant,
and when you block it,
it's not able to send
those chemical signals.
That's the best that's
the best explanation
that I can think of for
this behavior that we
see between between treatments
four and five.